il s'appelle orties osca oxmo leica ou
encore jim qu ils seront bientôt des
chiens détecteurs de co vite 10 d'ici
deux semaines
ils auront terminé leur formation à
l'école nationale vétérinaire d'alfort
tout comme leurs maîtres pompiers de la
brigade cynotechnique des yvelines
initialement ces pompiers et leurs
chiens sont spécialisés dans la
recherche de personnes égarées ou de
personnes ensevelies
l'objectif de ce nouvel apprentissage
détecter le coronavirus en reniflant on
apprend aux chiens à mettre le nez dans
des cônes latif danse économe fatigue on
va mettre des prélèvements de sueur
axillaires donc c'est à dire bien sûr le
sous les aisselles dans les cônes de
telle façon à ce que les chiens puissent
définir si c'est un prélèvement positif
on croyait vraiment négatif cette
formation intervient dans le cadre du
programme noah this dirigée par le
professeur dominique grandjean et en
collaboration avec l'université saint
joseph de beyrouth au liban
créé il ya deux ans avec son équipe le
professeur travailler avec les chiens
sur la détection médical notamment du
cancer du côlon
aujourd'hui avec la crise sanitaire son
programme a pris une autre tournure
honte et je me souviens début mars en
réunion dans mon bureau et ryad sarkis
qui est professeur à l'université de
beyrouth et le team de julien makemo la
coordinatrice en fait du programme de
maïs ils m'ont poussé dans mes derniers
retranchements me londres a essayé on a
essayé on va essayer c'est le démarrage
de ce que j'appelle laventure chien que
vite parce que depuis ça a pris une
ampleur à l'international surtout j'ai
quand même assez extraordinaire
cette formation est donc une première en
france mais aussi une première pour les
chiens des pompiers yvelinois il a
forcément fallu un petit temps
d'adaptation on a l'habitude d'avoir des
chiens qui sont libres sans contrainte à
courir un petit peu partout bien sûr
sous notre contrôle
et là on leur demande de mettre le nez
dans les cônes c'est quelque chose de
très précis de très contraignant pour
eux à voir ce qu'ils font d'habitude
donc au début c'est vrai que c'était un
petit peu
on va dire excité même si c'est pas
vraiment le terme exact et ils se sont
vraiment tous posé les chiens devraient
bientôt être opérationnels cela
permettrait à terme de diminuer les
tests pcr effectués sur les pompiers
yvelinois